Chicago police are looking for two
potential persons of interest in a
possible hate crime against actor Jesse
Smollett police say a surveillance
camera took these images of the two men
on the night Smollett says he was beaten
the star of the TV drama Empire said his
mask attacked her attackers yelled
racist and homophobic slurs Dean
Reynolds is tracking the investigation
dean good morning good morning
investigators are hoping the FBI can
enhance those images to provide some
distinguishing details now the men are
not considered suspects but the police
do want to know who they are and what
they were doing when Smollett says he
was attacked sources tell CBS News the
two figures seen in these dark
surveillance images were also spotted
sitting on a bench when jussie Smollett
walked past them across the street they
then appear to get up and follow him
although the three of them are never
seen on camera together about a minute
later investigators say another security
camera captured Smollett returning to
his apartment with a noose tight around
his neck the rope was untied but still
on his neck when police arrived 45
minutes after he says he was attacked
small a tag a cast member of the Fox hit
show Empire told police two masked white
men shouting racist epithets and gay
slurs beat him up knocked him to the
ground and doused him with an unknown
chemical after he left a Subway
restaurant around 2:00 a.m. on Tuesday
he also said his attackers allegedly
yelled Magga country a reference to
president Trump's campaign slogan was oh
god zookeeper
[Music]
smollett is known for speaking out
against racism and bigotry like in this
2017 music video he is also a frequent
critic of the president the actor was
the target of a threatening letter last
week which the FBI is now investigating
Chicago Mayor Rahm Emanuel what was done
here alleged done here is this police
are working on this has no place in the
city of Chicago
now police sources tell us that Smollett
says he was on the phone with his
manager during at least part of that
altercation but so far neither man has
agreed to turn over his cell phone for
examination Nora
all right team oh I know investigators
want to get the bottom of this thank you